joe rogan may be a pretty you know mild
reasonable guy he's fairly libertarian
but he is fairly
left on a lot of issues and so he might
you know he'll end up coming and then
what happens is with all of his good
intentions
he'll vote for someone who seems
moderate libertarian which will be
further left than the traditional
republican who runs in the area and then
it's just it's a slow process where it
the path to hell is paved with good
intentions yeah
didn't someone compare into rush
limbaugh today yes yeah washington
washington post said that joe rogan is
the next rush limbaugh
are you kidding me do you want to talk
about it i could see it yeah i mean
both bulbs sometimes check us out okay
so we
we do have the story from the washington
post it says rush limbaugh is ailing and
so is conservative talk radio industry
it's from paul farhi ah this guy this uh
we
we know paul and uh in in in this
he actually brings up this one point
about uh
basically the article is saying that
talk radio is is on the decline and that
means conservatives are are in trouble
but he says one very important thing the
shift makes someone like comedian joe
rogan
a libertarian with a hugely popular
podcast quote
the next rush limbaugh says paul matzko
the author of the radio right
how a band of broadcasters took on the
federal government and built the modern
conservative movement
well okay so far he isn't himself saying
that joe rogan is the next rush limbaugh
but that is
a heck of a statement to be made i would
i mean like in terms of
impact maybe i mean rush limbaugh has
been a force on the right
but joe rogan is not a force on the
right no joe rogan's not a force on the
right but he is a force
true but you know i guess in the idea of
influence in talk shows but
larry king had an influence in talk
shows yeah it's a wild stretch i mean he
could have said howard stern he could
have said that
people listen to rogan like a spiritual
guide kind of like how rush limbaugh
the problem is rogan doesn't puppeteer
the talking points he doesn't go along
with the agenda he actually questioned
things and he tries to rationalize them
instead of just pushing up propaganda
and that's why he's such a
battering ram yeah exactly that's why
it's so dangerous is because you get
someone who inspires you
to question the narrative and question
things as they are
questioning authority who wants but who
in authority wants that
rush limbaugh is a conservative with
conservative opinions
and when he tells stories and he talks
he's talking
it's not for for the most part but you
did explain to me as
off the show that there's no such thing
as the left and right anymore
it is oh that's yeah it is it is the
occult it's the cult and then
and then that cult so right now we're
looking at the example of
joe rogan's part of the not cult but he
hasn't his own cult
like following a few months if you want
to make that that uh comparison
and then but he's challenging everything
within that world cult for the most part
right
so yeah so i guess in that in that case
in that stance you're probably right
isn't it the weirdest thing
that left and right has nothing to do
with i don't i don't even you know look
we were talking earlier you you know i
said there's no real left and right
anymore you agreed you said it's a
horseshoe and i said it's a jackson
pollock painting
it's just yeah i don't know who's what
who's where so i can come out and be
like
all of my you know policy positions have
been traditional liberal but i think the
democrats are manipulative and they're
lying to people and the media is lying
too
and that's a right-wing position
apparently so i guess
i think we'll be all like by 2069
nice we'll be all uh a like a
homogenized like
you know we talk about the mixing bowl
that's when we'll all be homogenized
everybody literally
has a position takes every single
position on everything like hillary
clinton
what do you mean like she takes a
position on everything yeah
i mean there are a lot of things where
i'm like i don't know
you know keystone pipeline's a good
example the left says it's causing oil
spills and it's like okay and the right
says
freight delivery causes more oil spills
so keystone actually is an
improvement there we mentioned this on
the show the other day there's this meme
about
the us government spent millions of
dollars
developing a pen that can be used in
zero gravity so they can write while
they're in outer space
the russians use the pencil and then
everyone laughs
and these leftists share the meme saying
it was such a simple solution in america
waste all this money
and then the new meme now is someone
writing a correction saying
using a pencil can get particulate
matter from the pencil into the air
which can be dangerous for the
filtration system and what you're
breathing
and so because they need a purified
environment it is dangerous to use a
pencil
so the u.s created a pressurized pen to
use in outer space
for safety purposes it makes a ton of
sense when you don't understand and you
think you're smarter the simple solution
sounds like it's right
but in reality it wasn't makes me keep
thinking about this where when a new
person goes from california to texas
they want to
impose what they think is right and
often what you think is right
isn't so that's when like when when peop
when you want to push your beliefs
whatever they are you got to like look
at history and look at the patterns and
think of yourself as part of a pattern
i just think of myself as a dumbass
you're not a dumbass louis because
again you have to understand there's a
lot of stuff we don't know about and and
a lot of people think that they know
everything we don't
learn about let's let's talk about the
the subtle erosion when it comes to
politics
uh with joe rogan being the example of
like the new right
if we're talking about the left being
the cult and the right being the not
cult then
yeah i guess as strange as it might
sound joe rogan may very well be the
next rush limbaugh the only difference
is
joe is talking to people he's he's not
for the most part
uh getting up there and for hours
talking about how he feels about what's
going on so
there's a difference but in terms of
policy changes it's going to affect this
country
you know so so we're out here in the
middle of nowhere i've gone to a few gun
shops
and i was talking to this one guy and he
was saying oh we got all these liberals
moving in now you know because since
covid
and the riots and now they're coming to
buy guns and i'm like and i laughed and
i'm like i'm one of them
and then he gave me this look he was
just like uh and i'm like here's my you
know
former id from this you know very blue
place and i was like no don't look at me
man i'm not voting
and i was like because i don't know i i
lived in this place and it got bad
and now i'm coming new to a new place
i'll defer to you guys
and then he was like no just vote for
you know the people we tell you to vote
for and i was like
i'll just leave it to you i'm not going
to get involved but here's what happens
joe's a good dude
he's got a lot of good ideas and he's
fairly rational right
but he'll come in and and i mean with
the utmost respect
i don't think his intention is going to
be i'm going to turn this place deep
blue and make it as bad as california
because he fully understands why
california is bad so he's probably
he's probably soured on a lot of the
policies of california that are
deep blue however there are probably
some things where he's like look
i like that texas does a lot of these
things but there are some things i think
should change legalize weird
that's the slow erosion there's issues
pertaining to family there's issues
pertaining to
you know marijuana for instance that can
lead to bigger changes down the road
and as an individual person you might
not realize the correlation between one
policy and the next
so you might think it's no big deal that
i'm saying we should
allow or not allow this one particular
thing not realizing it is just one
domino being knocked over which
eventually
ripples down the line so let's say you
you know
want think marijuana should be legalized
you vote for it now all of a sudden you
get a bunch of dispensaries popping up
and a bunch of industries from
california and colorado blue areas
move into massive businesses and
relocate their employees sending in more
deep blue voters there's things like
that it's not it's not so cut and dry
yeah i mean you just got to get
republicans to start smoking weed and
you've got no problem you know
they'll become libertarians overnight
psilocybin yeah
you know you just gotta you just gotta
like slowly push that on them just be
like it's okay
like you can i laugh and joke but like
if everyone took
a dose of psilocybin i think this world
would be like drastically altered for
the better
i don't know about for the better
communication or they could freak out
and have a total like that will probably
happen
again when you're talking about
psilocybin your own personal decisions
some people have
really great amazing eye-opening uh
experiences like bill hicks
some people freak the hell out and have
horrible experiences
and because their self-control is trying
to limit to their kind of expansion and
they're fighting each other and that
fighting is hurt
it creates honestly this idea
they're already insane they're already
out of control and crazy
that's oversimplifying war we don't have
war because someone's just crazy there
are reasons behind why they declare war
and typically it's over
true you could have like the berserkers
the history was they would take
like crazy psychoactives and then go
into battle but they caught the point
so you can have a society that's on
psychoactives and violence so you're
right
right right but what i'm saying is you
said there would be world peace if
people did psilocybin
well communication is what really brings
it and i'll tell you learn
communications you could you could take
a world leader
and have them take shrooms and they're
still going to say but my country needs
oil
maybe and maybe not though i don't know
man you see outside the box on that
stuff
so you think that a country that's
heavily sanctioned like iran for
instance
and their people are starving and their
currency is hyperinflating that the
ayatollah takes shrooms and also is
going to be like
let my people die he'd probably be like
well oil is feeding my people so i can't
stop right now because they'll die but
as opposed to maybe the butt wasn't
there before i think i think
you know it's like saying a father would
sacrifice his kids if he took shrooms i
just don't see it sacrifice them why
let them die like a a leader of their
people in their country are not going to
abandon them simply because they had a
trip
you know what i mean but those are two
kind of extremes and you really kind of
have to experience it to understand what
kind of happens to you there's a lot of
possibilities in this kind of larger
spectrum
uh but there have been a lot of
scientific studies especially at micro
dosing
showing that it does actually help your
mental cognitive functions
increase and help cure a lot of ptsd and
a lot of other internalized kind of
depression-linked issues sure that that
couldn't be solved with other issues but
mushrooms specifically did in particular
studies so but
the issue i see is if you've got a
nation
and they're being besieged by another
nation repeatedly
and their people are being killed doing
shrooms won't change that fact that
they're being threatened and attacked
and they will respond in kind
it won't change the fact right that that
there's a siege they won't like
lift the siege but it will change the
way you view and your tactics so so let
me ask you if i was
throwing rocks at your face would you
stop me
yeah if you took shrooms and then the
next day i threw rocks to your face
would you stop me
so what how come there's no peace
there's external factors in war that's
not related to what you do with your
shrooms
someone taking psychedelics is not going
to change well i would stop you in
different ways
depending on depending on the situation
i just don't you'd build a wall
no i might throw it back at you you get
about to catch it or you know you'd
build a wall with the rocks that you're
throwing in the wall i have a simple
statement that i that i saw today in a
meme so it's now my philosophy that i
live by
and it says do not harm take no ish and
i think you know
ying and yang i think i think if people
have reasonable approaches like that i
think
they could go about things especially if
they have hope if they have their minds
opened up to new perspectives it could
go along in a way that could be a lot
more productive and conducive than doing
it
just the old-fashioned way and when you
look at psychedelic mushrooms they
usually help people realize those other
possibilities but again
not a medical doctor not recommending it
to you i know a lot of people that had
really bad trips
and had psychosis and dealt with some
really negative impacts
so if you're if you are going to do
something do your own homework do your
own research talk to some professionals
especially on this topic because it is a
very important one that you need to take
seriously
and not just decide from a youtuber and
i'm going to take a bunch of money so
so let's follow up on the initial
conversation you know i see a lot of
people moving to texas
and i'm just like why you know i've had
people say to me like you should move to
texas and i was like nah i'm not going
to go to
yeah everybody's moving austin didn't
elon musk go there yep
he's right outside austin elon and joe
and and who else went there
chappelle down there or is he just too
much uh no chappelle's in ohio yeah
california went to nashville nashville
california he left california but a lot
of people are going to texas a lot of
smaller youtubers but still like
prominent personalities are in texas
warm that's nice but will texas is it do
you guys really think this will make
texas turn blue do you think siraj
oh uh i don't know if it will i think
i've always thought it would
it would turn blue within like the next
10 years not this election um
but look just by pure
voting numbers if you looked at how
hillary clinton lost to
donald trump i think he lost she lost by
like 800 000 votes
uh beth o'rourke in the 2018 midterm
lost to
ted cruz about like 200 000 votes and
then i think
around in in this 2020 election
i think it was somewhere around a
ballpark of 100 to 150
000 um but it wasn't the
it wasn't the shift that i thought it
was going to be that was going to be
even much closer than that
but it's you know anything is possible
there's probably
texas is probably going to do something
that's going to alienate all the libs
and they're going to and they're going
to leave
like they did in georgia think about
this though
i mean the republican party today is
very different from where it was four
years ago and four years before that
it's being pulled to the left so for all
we know the democrats of this year will
be republicans in 2022
and then texas will stay red and
everyone's like oh look it's red but
it's actually
pretty far left yeah i mean the thing is
about yeah and that's the thing about
how progressives view
the democratic party in general and that
they are very much
the party they're very much like the
republican party of like the george w
bush years yeah to me it's also really
going to
depend on the immigration especially the
immigration that joe biden is letting in
and that's going to have a huge
tremendous effect that of course will
support a lot of democrats
and also what's happening on the
campuses i mean we have to understand
there's a new
kind of youth coming out directly from
universities and they're
inspired they're uh individuals that are
taught
a certain way of thinking that is
becoming prevalent that is supported by
the corporations that is supported by
hollywood that is supported by silicon
valley that is kind of eroding
any form of the old kind of fashion way
of living
i just realized why it's so important to
stand up and speak your mind and be
honest
it's not to change your minds it's the
kids the young 14 and 13
the impressionable people that are
forming their belief of what the world
is
it's affecting them like that's why it's
important to build culture
that's why it's important to do fun
things that inspire young people
and one of the problems i guess with
like talk radio is it's for people who
are already in the know
it's not but then youtube shows where 13
year olds log on that's why it's awesome
it's funny for the most part don't watch
political commentary they don't this
show is different you know they're on
tick tock
yeah they're they're on tick tock
talking now surprisingly i have a bunch
of videos on tick tock i didn't put
there
and you know i apparently get like
millions of views
epic yeah look i am a nobody i mean
i i i but i have young people reach out
to me all the time which is crazy
thinking that i'm like some sort of like
influence in their life and that means a
lot
because they say you are you are yeah no
it's and then i mean you start to
think about like what kind of impact you
actually are having on certain people
and it's tremendous the chinese kind of
implications here when it comes to tick
tock and also our
campuses and university is also
something that i think is really
prevalent
that we should be talking about because
according to campus reform they just
released an article according to their
source who allegedly works in ice
it was that joe biden our president just
recently
quietly ended a trump policy where
universities had to publicly release
their ties to the chinese government
and to specifically the chinese
confucius institutions
and now under this alleged new directive
according to campus reform
they'd no longer have to do that and
opening the door for chinese propaganda
yes and when you look at the influence
that the chinese government has been
expanding all over the world and
particularly in our institutions it
really makes you wonder
especially when you see the result of of
a quote university education
on the young children that are coming
out and their behavior in the world
which is
i would say somewhat fairly you know not
to be too hyperbolic but but essentially
destructive to
our way of life thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at
pm where you can leave comments and
super chat
and we actually will read your comments
on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you